I was just thinking about that I was
trying to work on a bit where you know
everybody wants bullying gone and it's
like there's not going to be any good
nicknames anymore you know like [ __ ]
teeth Sam you know and laser breath
Linda all these great nicknames people
aren't going to enjoy those anymore
a lot worse now those are like I guess
saying you know I could to make fun of
you now if you tried to call Malaysia
brother Linda they like kids have the
internet now they're probably worthless
yeah but I didn't know what I'm saying
is no nicknames will be around anymore
cuz we're good at school and you know
event but nicknames are gonna be gone
all right if you don't have a nickname
you're really not loved yes I never do
that Wow my mother pointed that I
[ __ ] hated the name Coco yeah why I
was old enough to live in Manhattan like
when I was a little on 88th Street I was
about six or seven I did not like the
name from Coco but I have another
predicament I didn't like the name Jose
even so I started thinking of my line
but wait a second my name is Antonia I
just call myself toady yeah so I even
got a ring made Tony I totally put on
everything I was like [ __ ] Tony P ony
told me that was it yeah and my mother's
like also Antonio and I would go no no
my name is Tony there you go you know
what Tony go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] Tony
makes I called myself Tony Tony
it look like you're channeling Tony and
that uh and then headshot the Comedy
Store put up the other night TV oh yeah
glasses let me tell you guys yeah who's
here on a [ __ ] Monday yeah and I had
to take that picture of 30 customers you
got ahead yeah yeah well you got a
headshot you got a headshot headshot
some guy that was a friend of a friends
yeah took those pictures and the glasses
with the chicks I was dates
oh just let me borrow away I guess a
comedy headshot yeah yeah yeah quiet
shot yeah yeah well I love that's one
thing I love about the store right now
the rebuilding the bathrooms and we got
to get those headshots back up because
it really gives it that sense of history
in there because I keep it when you look
at early ones of Ari Shaffir or early
ones of
you know Steve Rannazzisi all these guys
from years ago and you're like wow look
at how like like they're almost straight
like it shows you what we look like the
before picture I had it before then you
look at this now this is 20 years again
like smoke blown up your ass
Hollywood it'd be oh yeah Hollywood
abuse this is what you look like now I
all have my nursing have like very like
depressed looking head so like the every
headliner has like a serious headshot I
look at that headshot I looked at that
last night I lost that headshot that was
the car on my car my apartment got
[ __ ] toes now so had your heart
regarding felcher but at that time I
always saved five or six I shot right so
you don't know what what the [ __ ] is
gonna be and I I looked at the headshot
and I told her one thing but I wasn't as
old as I saw that was my movie yeah I
was totally young [ __ ] kid and my
booty I was 33 years old
pretty simple yeah yeah right exact I
was a [ __ ] young man and in my mind I
was in Hollywood mine at that time
that's [ __ ] old yeah that [ __ ] hole
like boy you're longer the tooth you
have lose weight get on I don't know
what we can do with you it was kind of
[ __ ] weird
yeah and I didn't I never took at any of
my angular [ __ ] what they had to say to
me really never mad at all yeah